well so think back on the first time you
bought Bitcoin I don't know when was the
first time you bought Bitcoin but the
first time I did was I wired some money
to a unknown Bank in Japan uh which
holds Bitcoin the the mount go cust uh
Bitcoin into custody that was DJs like
you're literally wiring wiring your your
own hard earned money into an offshore
bank that you have no idea about and I'm
sure a lot of people did this in the
early days so uh in my mind the early
adopters of Bitcoin were dents every
thing that I can think of that's
happening in crypto the first adopter of
everything of all these different
verticals are
be all right guys bang bang I've got
Chia here with me uh Chia I thought a
great place for us to start is you
recently wrote this excellent piece all
about DJ and how they are the pioneers
of crypto uh and I pulled out three
specific parts of of what you said and I
I just want you to expand on it the
first is speculation is the most
contrarian idea among Crypt VC
yet the most consensus idea among crypto
users explain that I I just noticed that
um again this is not all VCS but many
VCS are pretty disillusioned with the
current state of crypto which is
obviously very
speculative um but at the same time if
you look at Twitter if you look at
people around you everyone uses crypto
as a speculative tool so it's the most
consensus idea among the users but most
contrarian among among the VCS
why do you think it is that um
speculation is uh looked down upon even
though that is the thing that is
bootstrapping some of these networks
right and I say that from a perspective
of um I've gotten plenty of backlash
when I talk about traditional Finance
it's gambling right it's stock market is
a casino uh yes some people are much
better right you can be a professional
poker player and go play in the casino
or you can be a drunk you know 21y old
idiot and go play in the casino but
either way you're playing in a casino in
Las Vegas same thing in the stock market
you can have uneducated people or highly
sophisticated people it feels like
that's the same thing that's happening
in uh in kind of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency as well yeah um I mean I
have some hypothesis um but I feel like
in general the reason why speculation is
so looked down looked down upon is
because um most people think it's a zero
sum game whereas you know inventure
investing people think of it as a
positive sum game right like the average
VC makes money but the average Deen
loses money or uh well loses money after
uh transaction fees right so maybe
that's why but again like
it I think you have to take into into
account the fact that
there's people around the world who are
living paycheck by by paycheck and they
spend their entire entire childhood um
hustling for every single way to make
money and I think I personally don't see
anything wrong any moral issue with
speculation right like people have to
make money and in fact crypto is the
most open and transparent Casino out
there so I don't see that as a moral
issue at
all I actually would take a step further
I mean people are speculating with their
time when they go and work certain uh uh
jobs they are definitely speculating
with their money including they're
speculating with their money when they
buy bonds if they hold cash if they buy
real estate um and so the
interchangeability of the term
speculation and investing I think is uh
kind of one group of people saying hey
we're sophisticated the other group of
people saying you know and saying to the
other group you're not sophisticated uh
but you know there are plenty of people
who think buying a lottery ticket is
investing right I I don't know if I
would agree with them um but but is kind
of maybe a little bit of nuance around
words now a second thing that you said
in this piece is that degens which is a
uh a label or a name that is thrown
around quite often uh usually in a
pretty lovingly way uh in crypto but but
degens um is synonymous with early
adopters which changes the framework a
little bit of how you think about these
people explain this one well so think
back on the first time you bought
Bitcoin I don't know when was the first
time you bought Bitcoin but the first
time I did was I wired some money to a
unknown Bank in Japan uh which holds
Bitcoin the the mount go cust Bitcoin
into custody right that was like 10
years ago that was DJ as like
you're literally wir wiring your your
own hard hard hard earned money money
into an offshore bank that you have no
idea about and I'm sure a lot of people
did this in the early days so uh in my
mind the early adopters of Bitcoin were
Deens and then I'll give you three other
examples uh one is uh those nfts right
you know the the jpex the Penguins the
the Ducks the dogs right the meme coins
um people think of or VCS actually think
of nfts as a way to to create new IPS
right to compete with Pokemon to compete
with Hollywood
Etc um but if you look at penguin the
the P pinguin by for example um the jpex
have no utility yet except for um you
know uh showing them on your on your
Twitter putting them in your in your tw
Twitter pfp and so the first people who
buy the penguin jpack they are they're
they're
dents they're literally buying jpegs
that have zero utility and they're just
buying jpex for they're just buying the
jpex for the speculation for the upside
right so that's one example uh and then
another example is helium right the
decentralized um Telecom Network right
the first time you buy Helium um hotspot
or hotspots uh it costs about $1,000 and
in return what you earn is a very IL
liquid
token uh that's the helium token who in
the right mind would do this right again
it's the
dents um
so and then people would argue look uh
we still haven't seen a a true
non-speculative use case of crypto yet
but stable coins are actually taking the
adoption of stable coin is taking place
all around the world at a mindboggling
pace and guess what even the first use
case of stable coin was also very
speculative people use St Co stable coin
to do cross exchange Arbitrage and to do
leverage trading so everything that I
can think of that's happening in crypto
the first adopter of everything of all
these different verticals are
D when I see um stable coins being
spoken about in terms of speculation I
don't think people think about it that
way but it is a tool in the toolkit of a
Speculator is basically the argument
you're making right and so it's you may
not be speculating on the asset itself
but it is a tool that is used in the
process of speculating no different than
the people who go and you know uh go
west and try to dig for gold they need a
shovel right and so uh no one was
speculating on shovels but it is a
crucial component of the process of
speculating which I think is you know a
really interesting way of looking at
this the third thing that you said is
the decentralized Utopia needs the
open-minded risk-seeking
thrill-seeking pioneers and I thought
this was interesting because when most
people hear risk they run away when they
think of thrill in financial markets
they run away y are you making the
argument that these people are running
towards risk they're running towards
thrill and and actually that's an
important part of being a Pioneer is
being able to go and do that yeah and
the analogy I I draw here is uh the
early internet days right so in the
1990s the first users of Internet uh
used the first email clients or uh those
forums um before the likes of SSL were
developed which is a security standard
protocol um it just so happens that the
internet is the information Super
Highway and crypto is the financial
super highway so by definition the first
few adopters of crypto has to be those
super risk seeking early adopters
Pioneers right they seek risk they seek
thrill and without those um you know
those uh risk Seekers uh we actually
wouldn't know how truly scalable and uh
safe our our infrastructure is right
because all these dents that got hacked
or paying super high G gas fees without
them we wouldn't know how bad are you
know the the layer ones or or the
oracles or the bridges are and these
dents are what are the people that that
prompted our entire industry to focus on
on building better
infrastructure now you've also written a
piece that basically looked at uh hyek
and you made the argument that Hayek's
vision of an alternative currency may
actually be more akin to stable coins
than to bitcoin yeah now uh I don't
think you're saying Bitcoin is bad
actually think you're saying the
opposite which is like Bitcoin is great
and uh it definitely fulfills some
version of his view of the world but
explain a little bit the Nuance here if
we now have uh to some degree a
decentralized digital currency that is
completely outside the system in Bitcoin
and then we have this almost like
layered version of Fiat currencies and
stable coins and both of them seem to be
putting pressure on the Legacy system
but doing it in different ways and so
how do you view maybe what hyek was
really saying is the potential solution
and then how both of those fit into that
framework yeah so so that post that I
wrote was uh six years ago I don't even
remember exactly what I wrote but the
analogy I draw there was uh the the
exact mechanism of maker that the die in
The Maker maker Dow system resemble
the the duad which is the the uh
currency that hyek proposed um decades
ago um
but Bitcoin and stable coins play very
different roles today empirically right
Bitcoin is a Fiat debasement hedge it's
not an inflation hedge but it's a
debasement hedge whereas stable coin um
we we see people around the world
especially those in Latin America Africa
Middle East and Southeast Asia um
extremely strong demand from them um for
this for the digitized dollar right
which is stablecoin and in many ways
stablecoin is better than Bitcoin and
there's pros and cons of course but the
ways in which it's better than than
Bitcoin obviously it's one of them is
that it's less volatile right people
want to hold a stable store value and so
as a result they also use uh stable
point to pay each other uh more often
than than using Bitcoin or actually I
don't know that for sure but but the
trend is certainly um you know trending
towards using more stable coin versus
Bitcoin so it yeah it's interesting um I
do believe that uh stablecoin settlement
volumes is higher than Bitcoin
settlement volumes they're both growing
right which is which I think is a net
positive Tailwind for the industry um
but it does feel like uh stable coins
for medium of exchange again what are
they doing with it very clear uh there
are some questions about the metric
itself in terms of when you're actually
selling or buying is that getting caught
up in some of the transactions but all
that aside like it's definitely a
popular use case it seems that product
Market fit to use these stable coins uh
for medium of exchange now with that
said a question that comes to mind is
when hyek is talking about this he was
talking about one currency maybe
actually it should we have two like you
know if you talk to Michael sailor
Michael sailor will say well I think
that Bitcoin is going to be this amazing
store of value and it's going to be
surge um serve as digital gold and the
enemy is gold like you know drop your
gold buy Bitcoin um and at the same time
that Bitcoin is growing in popularity
and adoption and and price the dollar is
going to continue to strengthen and so
gold loses and weak Fiat currencies of
you know non- us Nations they
lose maybe stable coins actually are
what he's talking about there in terms
of US Dollars it's just in a digital
form right it's the same dollar same
monetary policy but it's Bitcoin and its
dollars that end up strengthening is
that kind of your view and then in terms
of solving for hiyes you know uh kind of
Utopia Vision we actually end up with
two currencies rather than one possibly
uh because by definition the problem
that stable coins still have is Fiat
debasement right yes US dollar just keep
getting debased again and again over a
long period of time and so you're going
to need a a hedge against that and that
is Bitcoin so it's very possible that
both will exist and you know obviously
all Reserve currencies all Fiat Reserve
currencies come to an end so maybe in
two to three four decades from now um
stable coins US dollar stable coins can
come to an end right in terms of
dominance but that'll take a long time
yeah it's it's fascinating to think
about um you've tweeted recently about
uh African startups using stable coins
and the popularity there um I was
shocked at uh maybe the responses that
people had I think they were surprised
um some of them didn't believe it right
uh but pretty much any company that I
talk to anywhere in the world from
Argentina and you know Venezuela where
inflation is ravaging these economies uh
all the way to um you know economies
even in the united St or uh companies
even in the United States where uh sure
we've had some high inflation but for
the most part people still have access
to Dollars stable coins efficiency speed
lowcost transactions uh seem to be very
attractive how do you see stable coin
adoption right now if we took a snapshot
of kind of the static uh environment is
this something where it's just these
Deens and kind of crypto forward or Tech
forward or do you actually see it
seeping into what I'll call kind of the
mainstream economies uh maybe outside
the United States yeah so I I'll throw
some numbers
um uh last year and this is according to
a report by BH dig digital uh $14
trillion worth of stable coin settled on
chain and that number surpassed the
amount the dollar amount that PayPal
handled last year it's
mindboggling now uh probably we don't
know this for sure but probably most of
that volume is uh related to trading uh
because people need to move stable point
across exchanges and then trade in those
exchanges but the percentage of
non-speculative usage of stable point is
probably growing in uh the emerging
economies um so uh in this recent uh
chin analysis
report uh which analyzed uh the the
adoption of uh
crypto um in
Africa uh Nigeria South
Africa are probably the top two I forget
the the number three but Nigeria South
Africa are the top two and
coincidentally uh most of the African
startups that I've uh spoken with that I
mentioned in that tweet are also from
the these two uh uh countries so my
empirical experience matches what uh the
data shows that's in Africa um people
use there there's a massive shortage of
dollar right now in in Nigeria for
example and that's one reason why people
want the digital dollar but another
reason is um you know there's there's
still a lot of migration happening in
Africa Africa is extremely fragmented
with a lot of countries there's a lot of
migration between them there's a lot of
migration between Africa and Europe for
example so one of the startups that I
talked to recently is they help Afric
Nigerians uh for studying in Turkey uh
to do crossb payment so because of the
migration there there needs there is a
lot of demand for remittance products
cross border payment and by the way
turkey is also another really
interesting country where uh stable or
crypto is is
happening um some of you might might
have gone to um uh that conect recently
but uh the the startup that I talked to
uh they're not based in Ean they're
based in a smaller city in Turkey and
they told me that in that City there's
more
crypto uh physical shops than Bank
ATMs it's crazy uh so that's turkey and
then Latin America mostly Argentina
Venezuela and Colombia uh Brazil less so
because Brazil currency is relatively
more stable than Argentina for example
um and yeah those are the the regions
I'm mostly excited about it feels like
um you know for a long time when people
talked about Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
as a broader industry uh it was kind of
like um I think Alex gladstein from the
human rights Foundation calls it
Financial privilege we go to the ATM
money comes out right the dollar yeah it
gets debased but not nearly as fast as
elsewhere um and so it's hard to see
some of the value proposition but if you
go to turkey Lebanon Argentina Etc it
becomes very obvious and it's not just
what I'll call like the economic view of
let me get a bunch of data and see how
high is the inflation rate or let me see
what you know some of the uh um interest
rate decisions are it's also simple
things like hey I need to go to a
physical store I've got a friend who um
he worked at Uber for a while and one of
the things that he was um tasked with
was fraud prevention specifically in
Southeast Asia and so uh one of the
problem problems that makes it so
difficult is that there's a lot of cash
payments physical cash payments well how
does Uber make sure that the driver
actually got paid how does Uber get
their cut right and all these kind of
nuances to it and it feels like that's
really what's happening is we're almost
like modernizing the infrastructure to
some degree of some of these uh
locations and these geographies that is
as simple as moving from a physical
we're skipping over electronic and we're
going right to digital and so that
disruption ends up actually uh helping
them leap fraud
and we've seen this where you know um I
don't know in Nigeria for example
there's a very young population very
kind of uh High penetration of mobile
phones and internet access they never
got to kind of 2.0 of the internet they
went from basically 1.0 to now they're
jumping into 3.0 and that 2.0 you know
part where they were behind in some
cases they may actually be ahead of the
US it seems like today's episode is
brought to you by trust and will I've
gone through a number of different
changes in my life over the last few
years I I got married I had a kid and I
had to start thinking about how could I
ensure that my wife and my child would
be okay if anything ever happened to me
that's where trust wills and estate
planning come into play now most people
what they do is they get introduced to a
friend an uncle or someone in their
local community it tends to be someone
who's really expensive a lawyer an
accountant or somebody who does Estate
Planning and they just simply are using
a one-size fits-all template and just
telling you pay me thousands of dollars
and I'll use the same thing for you as
the guy down the street but that's not
what trust and will does
they have a trusted online estate
planning product that starts as low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all all your estate planning
documents so go to trustand will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp yeah
uh this uh leap frogging
phenomenon uh it's very interesting
because uh basically you're saying the
2.0 is not 10x better than the 1.0 but
the 3.0 is and therefore people just go
straight from 1.0 to 3.0 uh there's also
phenomenon like this outside of crypto
so for example in China uh two to three
decades ago people use physical cash uh
for for day-to-day payment um and then
at some point when mobile internet
happened people started using
WeChat uh and and use WeChat to pay leap
frogging credit card credit card is not
a thing in China but credit card is
extremely widespread in in the US right
um but not that not that many people use
Apple pay so Apple pay is like the next
level the the the 3.0 so to so to speak
not that many people use Apple pay
because Apple pay is like maybe not 10x
better than using a credit card for a
lot of people whereas in China people
just went straight from physical cash to
Mobile payment when you see that is it
the technology or is it the user
experience and obviously they're
intertwined but one of the things that's
interesting to me is um I don't know I'm
probably like habitually trained at this
point Bill comes I reach for my wallet I
don't reach for my phone right and like
as stupid as that is it's almost like a
user Behavior thing that you have to
change more so than oh is the technology
or better yeah like like obviously the
technology is better but there is
friction or there's a hurdle to get me
to reach for my phone versus reach for
my wallet when the bill comes or when I
go to pay for something and it feels
feels like that's really where uh the
opportunity is yeah yeah the the the ux
needs to be 10x better and obviously
it's technology that enables that um
I'll give you a related example of uh uh
uh in crypto actually so metamask
yesterday
rainbow uh launched a sort of a vampire
attack on
metamask um uh basically they tried to
airdrop uh points to mamas users in
order to entice them to use rainbow
instead um I I've always used metamask
in my entire life for the last five
years despite all the ux pain I've gone
through like hundreds of failed
transactions etc etc it's really really
painful but I continue to use it and the
reason why is um I've never lost money
on manam mask I've never been hacked on
manam mask so I I trust the
security so
basically the ux of metamask is bad but
the alternatives are not 10x better for
me to
switch and so that goes back to your
point about um whether or not mobile
phone is HX better enough than than than
credit cards to entice you to use it
let's talk about uh a recent development
um you know I through one of the funds
that I raised early on um have been an
investor in coinbase for a number of
years um you know it went public I think
that people looked at it very much as
the leading uh us-based regulated
exchange uh obviously there's been some
appetite for that from public markets
but it was essentially looked almost as
like you know the New York Stock
Exchange or the NASDAQ for crypto uh
over the last couple of years uh maybe
even last 18 months um I think you and
others have called out they've done a
fantastic job of morphing themselves
while still keeping that business still
you know kind of being a dominant
us-based regulated exchange they've
become much more Crypton native
they've got the wallet they've got the
L2 all this kind of stuff let's talk
about bass for a little bit maybe you
can kind of talk through like what is
bass and and why do they seem to one
being successful with it but also two it
feels like you know if I talk to will
Clemente from uh reflexivity research He
he'll say Wall Street is going to be
completely blindsided by what is
happening in uh coinbase's crypto native
side because they're only evaluating
trading fees and and kind of the the you
know web two type business yeah so Bay
is uh
an optimistic roll up on top of ethereum
and coinbase is behind it now I don't
know exactly what the relationship is
structured between coinbase and
Bas um but I do think that Bas will be a
top three Contender for the most
important rollup in the coming cycle and
unfortunately I don't think they will
launch a token um so I don't know what's
the best way to to gain exposure to to
base um is just by coinbase is it just
by coinbase stock the thing with
coinbase is uh I mean has a lot of other
things right yeah so it's not the purest
uh form of bet on on Bas itself I mean I
have an idea but it's it's uh almost
embarrassing to say but the my idea is
to to buy the the most Lindy meme coin
on
Bay and uh it's Toshi it's it's it's a
cat mecoin on PO there's not a dogcoin
yet um but there is a cat so so uh
explain explain that explain that a
little bit more in terms of why because
I think people are fascinated again we
we kind of get into the dgen speculative
you know uh uh ground here buying a meme
coin on top of Bas you think is the best
way to play Bas potentially being
successful why yes on on ironically um
and I say this both from a theoretical
and empirical uh point of view
theoretically um mecoin I I consider
mcoins as a
um crypto is is essentially tokenized
mind share tokenized attention right you
have all these different different coins
that that in theory have zero utility
but why are they commanding like 10
billions of dollars of of uh valuation
right it's it's because of the attention
behind them and memes like do Sheba
these bnk on salana these things they
capture a lot of attention and that's
why they're able to command an extremely
high valuation
and so if Bay the L2 that the rollup
doesn't launch their own
token
um the the most uh
uh uh the bet that will capture the most
value that will capture the growth of
coinbase I think is is a mean coin uh
for better or
worse I mean so far that has been uh a
huge part of crypto in general and and
you know I would even argue uh uh I've
had multiple people that are well known
on Wall Street like roll over and you
know basically want to kick me out of
their office I've been like well Bitcoin
has been the most successful meme coin
right in the sense of that there is this
culture there is this kind of mtic
aspect to it um but uh yeah Toshi is
obviously very different and an
interesting idea talk a little bit more
about bass itself in terms of just like
becoming this like de facto chain for I
I think you view it as like a regulated
defi chain what exactly do that that
that's part of it I'll explain but base
is um probably the most interesting
layer too because of the fact that it's
the coinbase is behind it and the result
of that is number one coinbase has over
100 million kyc
user and it would be a lot easier for
them to put that identity that kyc
identity on chain onto their own chain
than all the other chains right the
other chains they don't have this ident
ID
layer so the moment you have kyc on
chain you can do some really interesting
things that other chains cannot do for
example uh rwas so real estate uh real
world assets uh for example tokenized US
Treasury tokenized US Stocks tokenized
uh properties that kind of stuff because
these things typically require uh kyc
some of them require
accreditation um and uh you know for for
their users to be able to access these
uh uh instruments on chain right and
it's not easy for other chains to do it
so and therefore it's not easy for other
chains to to launch uh RW like this kind
of products RW product startups they
have extremely high startup cost due to
compliance due to Legal Etc um and
coinbase solves some of that so
um that's why I find coinbase really
interesting so so the first reason is is
the identity layer and the second reason
is is even more obvious which is the
fact that coinbase has a huge
distribution they can quite easily
direct their existing uh centralized
exchange users onto their own chain via
um coinbase wallet for example so the
distribution and the brand matters a lot
now do you think that this is uh when we
talk about real world assets are we
talking about them literally you know
putting real estate putting uh stocks
things like that or they're almost like
crypto native real world assets it's
something different no it's it's
literally tokenized stocks real estate
properties not crypto and and what is
the we talked about user experience in
terms of you know when the bill comes I
got to grab my wallet versus my phone
what will it take to convince Wall
Street or traditional Finance folks to
buy the tokenized version with they're
not going to be convinced the the the
reason so by the way I I've been
skeptical of uh real world outset for
many years until maybe three months ago
and I had a Epiphany which is that the
the first source of demand for rwas is
actually crypto Natives and the reason
for that is if you look at the the
market the total market cap of crypto
today is like 1.5 to to2 trillion so
there's two trillion doll worth of
onchain
wealth and at the same
time
it's likely that this will be the last
cycle the last 10x cycle right so
Bitcoin ethereum have maybe 10x more to
go before they reach more of a steady
state so at some point the crypto
natives all all these2 trillion dollar
worth of onchain wealth crypto natives
they need new ways to diversify they
need to diversify their wealth outside
of Crypton native assets and rwas are
are a pretty obvious way to do that to
to enable uh diversification for the
crypto natives so basically RWS solved
the problem of diversification for
onchain Deens or people living in uh
Emerging Markets uh needing new assets
and by the way RW RW RWS might still
sound controversial to a lot of people
but if you really think about it stable
coins are a form of rwas it's tokenized
US
dollar so many people either were not
around or have forgotten but back in
2017 and 2018 I would talk
quite a bit about tokenize the world
right and this idea was basically every
single asset is going to get tokenized
and brought on chain um I came to two
conclusions during that time period one
was we this is so far away that I should
just shut up and like you know I'm gonna
be saying the same thing for literally a
decade before this happens um and so
like it's always easier to see where the
world is going but it still takes time
to get there um but two was uh I thought
that we were going to have to uh see the
current generation of decision makers at
the Wall Street firms leave and have the
young people assume their positions of
decision- making and capital allocation
and then it would happen it's an
interesting nuance and actually uh I
could be convinced that you're more
right in the sense of no it's not even
the Wall Street firms it's actually just
the crypto natives end up actually being
that first you know group of early
adopters um and then to some degre
against yeah Wall Street has to follow
uh the Deens but the Deens are the
Pioneers y yeah it's super fascinating
um the last thing I want to talk to you
about is uh artificial intelligence in
crypto
um I have for a long time said that
Bitcoin is an automated Central Bank I
don't think that means that it's
artificial intelligence I don't think
that there's machine learning or or
anything like that but to a degree it is
this uh uh uh fits in very nicely into a
world view of um um what I'll just call
like automation in general right and so
artificial intelligence piece of that
machine learning but also crypto assets
as well how do you see artificial
intelligence and crypto kind of
intersecting or where do you think the
areas of opportunity are yeah okay so
first of all I I have no idea where
where AI will be going
because AI is is Just Happening as fast
as crypto and I spend all my time in
crypto so there's no way for me to truly
understand deeply understand AI but I do
have some hypothesis
um one idea is uh right now there is a
massive shortage of
gpus uh because everyone needs gpus to
train
models and so uh where crypto might come
into play is to create uh decentralized
marketplaces of gpus where you know the
consumers like you and I we have iidle
gpus on our
laptop um if I'm not using using my
laptop maybe I can contribute my gpus to
this network to help others to train
their models and earn some tokens and
money in
return uh but it doesn't have to be a
consumers it could be some idle gpus
sitting in a big data center as well
right so that's one idea uh obviously
there have been some a few startups that
have that that got tens of millions of
funding pre-product Market fit
pre-product actually so I think a lot of
people actually see this already as a
big
opportunity um another way where uh
crypto and AI could intersect is um some
time ago there was a a pretty big hype
cycle around AI
agents uh and the way we we can Define
that is AI agents that that run
autonomously uh rather than like a SAS
product or something right um and so uh
if AI agents by the way I haven't seen
any truly useful AI agents yet by that
definition but if AI agents will happen
then at some point they need to make
payments they need to do make Financial
transactions and guess what crypto is
the most compatible form of payment and
uh custody for for AI because crypto is
permissionless and it's programmable and
so is
AI um it's it's almost like what you're
saying is um whether it's Bitcoin stable
coins maybe even something else uh
it's money for machines yes 100% yeah
and you need the automated transactions
like for a long time I've always said um
there is this uh belief that everything
will become more and more automated and
you will trust the algorithms obviously
you know you trust Google to tell you
where to go you trust Spotify to tell
you what music to listen to whatever um
but you can't use two-day settlement
times of you know Fiat right and and so
really you're saying we need a different
asset with a different settlement time
to be able to uh unlock automation
settle settlement time matters and
programmability also matters so imagine
you have a personal AI assistant that
runs autonomously and you ask the agent
to hire more specialized agents to do
specialized work for you um to I don't
know schedule meetings uh that kind of
stuff right and then your personal agent
will need to pay the specialized agent
and and guess what kind of money they're
going to use to make that payment it's
going to crypto because it's
programable yeah it's super interesting
um when you almost think about you know
I for a long time have I think I've been
written pieces years ago about this like
money for machines idea but uh if you
almost put together how do I want to
invest in artificial intelligence you
can go invest in you large language
models and and you know things like open
AI uh whatever um then there are uh you
know maybe like products and services
that are built using Ai and kind of like
end consumer um opportunities but maybe
there is uh an even bigger opportunity
if you really want to own the payment
rails of artificial intelligence then
you need to be investing in crypto and
if you were to put these investment
opportunities uh next to each other
which one is more asymmetric right is
there more kind of value to be captured
by investing in what right now is being
categorized as AI or is it actually to
be uh allocating to you know kind of
crypto and that's where the value gets
captured by the way you would be
surprised how many stocks are they're
actually AI stocks but people don't
think of them as AI stocks yet because I
spent a lot of time looking at AI stocks
as well especially
semiconductors uh there are quite a few
of them that are to me really
undervalued and and and like everyone is
talking about Nvidia
nvda
uh by the way Nvidia is the purest form
of of AI bet but there there's many
others uh that are doing AI related
stuff both on the semi Hardware side as
well as application side talk us through
maybe a couple that you're like uh hey
these are AI companies but no one has
realized it yet this episode is brought
to you by cal.com what do I have in
common with Chad Hurley from YouTube
Toby from Shopify and Alexis from 776
and the co-founder of Reddit we all use
cal.com instead of cly and we are all
early investors as well cal.com is
leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for
League corporations and Tech gurus if
you like to have your calendar organized
and be able to have an efficient
exchange when scheduling but you love
all of the benefits of open- source
technology then cal.com is for you they
are transforming sophisticated calendar
management into an accessible tool for
all via a userfriendly interface you can
customize it and you can make your
calendar work for you use code pomp for
$500 off when you set up your team with
cow.com today again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open-
Source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time uh snowflake is
one that's more on the infrastructure
side so they provide um uh database
infrastructure and at some point people
are going to realize a company like this
is obviously an AI play
um and uh there's a couple of uh
semiconductor companies that are doing
more and more stuff in AI they're more
they're they're currently generalized uh
semiconduct conductor but obviously the
AI force is so strong that it's going to
convert them into doing more and more AI
so
asml uh
ACLS uh these are the the semiconductor
companies that don't produce or don't
Fab fabricate the the the chips
themselves but produce the the tools the
equipment for other uh Fabs to create uh
chips so the supply chain goes like this
you have asml ACLS and others they
produced the manufacturing equipment and
they sell the equipment to the lik of
TSM so taian Semiconductor Company and
Intel and then these two uh they have
Fabs so they have like physical places
where the chips are are manufactured and
they manufactur the chips for NVIDIA
Nvidia is fabulous so Nvidia produces
designs the chips uh for uh open AI for
example so that that's that's how the
supply chain goes
and the most surprising thing about the
hardware AI companies is that their
profit margin is so incredibly high it's
like 30% 40% or even more and what that
tells me is that their Tech is has
extremely strong mode they're probably
10 years ahead five to 10 years ahead of
their competitors it's very hard for
competitors to to outperform to to out
compete them that's why these Hardware
companies are so interesting to me
they're both undervalued and have
extremely high uh profit
margin now are there companies that um I
think cor weave was a big one in crypto
that uh they had a bunch of
infrastructure mining equipment Etc they
pivoted very nicely um are there other
companies that maybe are getting
categorized right now as crypto
companies that you actually think are AI
companies there are a lot of crypto
protocols that are doing AI related
stuff um but to the best of my knowledge
there is none that is production ready
and got it that that is simply because
uh AI is already hard enough and now
you're slapping decentral
decentralization on top of it you have
two really hard problems to solve
at the same time um so it'll take them
um quite some time to get to get
ready when you see um Capital flows to
me it feels like there was tons of
capital that poured into crypto right
more broadly uh 2020 2021 massive bull
market it's almost like the world it's
like that Meme you know the guy turned
his head and all a sudden AI took a lot
of the capital flows and crypto kind of
fell out of favor um yeah in the future
is it just
Capital will flow into kind of you know
um pioneering Tech and crypto and AI
will be side by side or do you think
we'll still kind of get this oscillating
back and forth between two industries
that maybe are you know tangentially
related but people will still keep them
in separate buckets and and kind of go
risk on crypto and then pull back and go
risk on
AI I I have no idea but empirically this
year uh coinbase point the stock
outperformed Nvidia and by the way
Nvidia is the number one best performing
stock in all of S&P 500 it's up like
250% or something and coinbase is up
like 300 so both went up uh there's no
Capital flow that went from crypto to uh
to to AI or vice versa and so whether or
not this holds in the future I have no
idea but I do think that in general the
the money will flow into High um um you
know Frontier technology sectors and by
the way here's another thing I realized
recently which is um I wish I realized
this earlier you have all these macro
Lars that talk about how you know only
five stocks in the S&P 500 drive all the
returns in s&p500 right and the the the
remaining of the 495
stocks hasn't haven't moved this year
but it it turns out that maybe public
stocks also also follow Venture returns
profile
right you have 500 stocks but maybe only
a few of them drive all the returns just
like inventure and this certainly was
not the case like 50 years ago but today
it could very well be that that's the
case because we're literally nearing the
The Singularity like you have a bunch of
Technology sectors um that are just
evolving extremely fast um and um that
all the top five or seven stocks in the
S&P 500 that are driving all the returns
are tech stocks in Ai and basically all
of them are AI if you think about it
right like Facebook is AI Google is AI
Microsoft is AI Tesla is AI Nvidia is AI
all of them are AI right so um maybe
public markets also follow mental
returns I'll take it a step further um I
have a uh letter to investors sitting in
my drafts that is called the power law
era and it talks about this but not just
uh the five stocks in the S&P 500 it
does two things uh one it looks at um
all markets across Market Cycles across
asset classes Etc or power laws and
actually have been for a long time
people just didn't realize it and I got
this idea because uh there are two
brothers from New Zealand called the
Chandler brothers that a lot of people
don't know about but essentially the
story is their parents start Ed the
largest department store in New Zealand
kind of you know the Neiman Marcus if
you will of New Zealand and they went to
college um and when they came back they
were like hey guys uh we don't want to
run the department store but like we
like investing why don't we sell the
family business get the cash and like
we'll go invest they did when they sold
the family business they got about $10
million at the time and in a 20-year run
they turned $10 million into $5 billion
so no outside investors just pure invest
and when they looked at all of their uh
Investment Portfolio and returns it
boiled down to about five Investments
they made over those 20 years that drove
all the returns and so when they looked
at it they realized about 5% of all the
decisions they had made drove 95% of the
outcomes and so they became very
interested in this idea of power laws
Etc and so if you then go and you
actually extrapolate this outside of
financial Market in your life power laws
dominate everything right you probably
have five to 10 personal relationships
that actually are the outsized you know
um kind of contribution to happiness or
to uh meaning if you think of you know
trips that you make right if I ask you
hey where have you you know traveled to
you probably will think of three to five
trips that you've made in your entire
life of all the days you've been on
Earth right and those are the things
that you kind of remember and so it is
this very weird dynamic where like maybe
actually power laws are the default
across financial markets across life
across all these different things um but
because the human brain brain really
can't think in exponentials and and
understand power law we just assume it's
the opposite and so what you're really
getting at here is like we're we're
uncovering in some weird way because of
our access to information and also uh um
the severity now of underperformance and
outperformance what's actually been true
for you know decades in uh financial
markets as well and by the way this is
why the the hodlers Bitcoin hodlers were
so preed like if if Bitcoin goes up twox
and you sell it you're never going to be
able to capture this power
law um the in my 10 years in crypto my
best basically 95% of my money comes
from just holding for 10 years and never
selling I I wrote a piece uh earlier
this week and I said that uh Bitcoin
essentially took Financial discipline
and codified it by really looking at if
you look at you know to use Bitcoin but
but I think across crypto this ends up
being true
um all of the great details and Nuance
of great investors are part of the
Bitcoin culture Warren Buffet buy great
assets and never sell them right uh
dollar cost average right don't look at
the price just buy consistently over a
long period of time um when things go on
sale buy more right I mean you just kind
of look at all these different
components and you realize like wait a
second in some weird way crypto although
there is speculation although there is
Deens although there is all these things
that people kind of you know uh thumb
their nose at it's actually taught an
entire generation how to be great
investors and uh that I think kind of
blows people's mind and if you go and
you you know if you walk into a hedge
fund on Wall Street like yeah the crypto
people actually understand investing
better you know you'll get thrown out
but you know if you dollar cost average
since the beginning of January 2021 so
basically you said I wrote all the way
up the market and I wrote it all the way
down and back to where it is now and you
were buying Bitcoin when it was over
valued you were buying it when it was
undervalued you're up like 50% by simply
just dollar cost averaging on a daily
basis and so um it is a very weird
phenomenon
100% what are you most excited about
let's say in this coming bull
market
um I've already mentioned a few payment
stable coin
rwas um they're all under discussed just
because speculation is what drives all
the attention stable point is boring rwa
is boring they're Boomer even but I'm
really excited I think both are still
fairly
contrarian um Bay I'm excited uh bay
again probably top three Contender for
the most important uh layer to on
ethereum uh salana I'm I'm very excited
uh obviously there has been a lot of
hype
recently um B salana is fundamentally
different from ethereum uh making good
tradeoffs um I'm excited about
that uh I'm excited about meme coins uh
I'm excited about penguins py penguins
on
ethereum um mat Lads on on on
salana uh B
salana hosi on on Bas um all this D
stuff I'm
excited um I'm excited about coin the
stock oh I'll throw another name Circle
if Circle
uh successfully ipl's next year I think
Circle will be the purest form of bet on
the growth of stable coin around the
world because that's literally the only
thing they they do usdc so fingers
crossed I was already investor in circle
by the way fingers crossed on um then
successfully IPO next
year uh what else um that's a pretty
good list
yeah that's a fantastic list uh um Chad
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh or or find out more
about Alliance sty um you can find me on
Twitter uh qwq IO so my initials my
first name uh Alliance style our website
is alliance.
XYZ um and uh yeah that's it awesome
well I really appreciate taking the time
to do this your uh your tweets are
awesome they make me think every time
you tweet so please keep it up and
definely in the future thanks for having
me